it's a book of essays of stories from my
life that are humiliating and funny and
painful and happy you know it's just
what's happened to me in 35 years Amy
Schumer gets candid about a lot of
topics in her new book the girl with a
lower back tattoo and dating is no
exception
et's Cameron Mathison sat down with the
funny gal Tuesday in New York City where
she opened up about her love life past
and present in the book you recount some
of your past relationships a lot of your
past relationships and then how some of
the guys treated you really horribly did
you reach out to them give them a heads
up no no I changed their names but the
guys in the chapters that are most
difficult I was in an abusive
relationship and the way I lost my
virginity I did not reach out to this
I'm not I'm not in constant contact with
those guys if you can believe it or not
these days amy has found happiness with
furniture designer Ben Hanish the couple
started dating
earlier this year he's is very
supportive and loving and and I think
we're just really proud of each other
and yeah and he like is so far removed
from this business that it's really nice
but when it comes to Amy's business it
doesn't get bigger than Meryl Streep who
recently revealed she wants a me to play
her in a movie about her life someday
come on what was your reaction to that
no I no I just screamed it was just it's
funny that people are is it happening
I'm like no she's alive thank God but it
just God there's no higher praise from a
higher person